This little icon means sharing.
And it's awesome on Android.
You can build an
action_send intent yourself,
but I prefer using ShareCompat,
and share text with just
a single command.
I mean like-- and
I'll go through what
it takes to correctly share
content to other apps,
as well as receive that content.
What kinds of content?
We saw text, but how
about HTML formatted text,
files, images, is such
a thing even possible?
Yes, it is.
So let's just do it.
Share some text.
ShareCompat does the hard work
of constructing our intent.
We just have to make sure
to set the MIME type.
This is how apps filter
what type of content
they can receive.
Then, call startActivity.
We wrap it in resolveActivity.
This prevents activity not
found exceptions for cases
where there is
actually no app that
can handle what we're sharing.
Better safe than sorry.
That was too easy, though.
Let's do HTML text--
ooh, as in email.
Well, not much more to it.
HTML text uses setHtmlText.
Makes sense.
We added a subject and we
can add multiple to, cc,
or bcc email addresses.
They only apply to email
apps, but that's fine.
Receiving apps can
ignore them if they want.
You just give it all you've got.
But talking about
the sending side,
without talking about
the receiving side,
is like talking about peanut
butter without mentioning
jelly, or something that.
The receiving activity
would need an intent filter
with the appropriate MIME type.
We'll note, we add
the category.DEFAULT.
You won't get any of our
startActivity implicit intents
we've created without it.
Category.BROWSABLE is
what allows websites
to directly share into the app.
Then, whether the sender
used sharedCompat or not,
you can use
intentReader to extract
the information you need.
But text, formatted or
not, is a bit basic.
Let's move on to the cool part--
sharing, say, ooh, an image.
Now, we're getting somewhere.
OK, so setStream is new.
Except where do we
get that uriToImage?
Here's the interesting part.
You'd think this could be a
file path to the image itself.
That's actually a
really bad idea.
That means you need to write
the file somewhere accessible
to other apps,
potentially needing
the WRITE_STORAGE permission,
and the receiving app
would definitely need the
READ_STORAGE permission.
With Android 6.0
Marshmallow, those
are dangerous
permissions that need
to be requested at runtime.
Don't be that app.
Instead, we have a
whole training doc
on correctly sharing files in
a way that requires no storage
permission using FileProvider.
Check out our blog post and docs
for how to set it all up first.
So what does our
code look like now?
We've used file
provider's getUriForFile
to get a sharable URI, suitable
for passing to another app.
Awesome.
We even get a way of determining
the type automatically
from the file.
Under the hood, this
approach uses what's
called URI based permissions.
The sending app
grants permission
to just the single URI.
We grant permission by
calling setData with our URI,
and then adding the
FLAG_GRANT_READ_URI_PERMISSION.
That's it.
Now, the receiving side
can use getContentResolver
openInputStream
to get the image.
So we know how to share text
and files to other apps,
as well as receive
those files, all
without dangerous permissions.
Hope this helps you
play well with others
and build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]